con nuestro segundo invitado el día
vamos a hablar sobre la movilización
anti lgbtiq más que va en aumento en
Estados Unidos donde desde 2020 ha
estado hasta lo que va de año se ha
registrado la violencia política contra
esta comunidad además también de
manifestaciones anti lgbtiq más y la
participación de la extrema derecha en
la actividad contra este colectivo
saludamos entonces a Sam Jones él es
jefe de comunicaciones de location and
even that project Gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de jueves Sam y le
pregunto qué datos aporta entonces este
informe y cuáles son las conclusiones
del mismo sobre el aumento de la
violencia contra la población lgbti
q más en Estados Unidos
es una organización de investigación
global que recopila datos sobre
incidentes de violencia política así
como protestas contra otras actividades
estratégicamente significativas no
violentas como el entrenamiento de
milicias y eventos de propaganda
comenzamos a recopilar estos datos en
los Estados Unidos específicamente en
2020 antes de las elecciones
presidenciales a medida que aumentaban
los riesgos de la violencia política y
más temprano de este año en particular
el mes del orgullo en junio
comenzamos a ver un aumento en la
actividad anti lgbtq como protestas
contra los eventos del orgullo y actos
de violencia política donde se tomaban
por objetivo a los miembros de esta
comunidad y luego hubo un acto de
violencia que fue frustrado Y que iba a
ser perpetrado por el grupo de odio
Así que en ese momento nuestros datos
indicaron que 2022 estaba en camino de
ser realmente el peor año para las
actividades anti lgbtq estas protestas
esta violencia todo esto desde que
comenzamos a recopilar los datos en
Estados Unidos y la semana pasada
hicimos una actualización de ese
análisis tras el tiroteo en el Club en
Colorado Springs y luego de actualizar
la información de alguna manera se puede
confirmar que este año es realmente el
peor hasta la fecha para las actividades
en contra de la comunidad lgbt y que
están en los niveles más altos desde que
comenzamos a recopilar datos en 2020 y
algunas de las cifras clave que
extrajimos de los datos es que ya hemos
registrado casi 200 incidentes desde
mediados de noviembre en la incidencia
de actividad anti lgbtq que triplica a
lo correspondiente a todo el año pasado
y se multiplica por 12 la cantidad
registrada en el 2020 Así que esta sería
la mayor incidencia de esta actividad
Así que esta violencia política se ha
triplicado este año y las demostraciones
contra la comunidad lgbtq sean duplicado
lo que también es particularmente
preocupante Es que dentro de esto
podemos ver que los grupos violentos de
extrema derecha como pecho Front que
mencioné anteriormente y otras milicias
han aumentado específicamente su
compromiso contra la comunidad lgbtq y
más a tres veces este año como estos
grupos están armados y vinculados a
índices más altos de violencia en las
protestas eso es particularmente
preocupante
sí le pregunto Sam quién está entonces
detrás de estos hechos de violencia
serían los grupos de extrema derecha
si en general uno de los actores
principales que están involucrados en
liderar algunas de estas actividades de
protesta así como la violencia que sale
de estas manifestaciones y ya sabes el
target político enfocado en la comunidad
lgbtqi está liderada en gran medida por
los grupos que mencioné como actores de
extrema derecha como los Boys y también
Nosotros hemos visto un aumento en actos
de violencia mucho menos organizados y
espontáneos que son potencialmente
inspirados por el aumento de La retórica
anti lgbtqi y contra la comunidad
hemos visto ciertos individuos
perturbados que no están afiliados a
estos grupos pero que salen al final a
la calle apuntan a un restaurante que
tuvo un evento del Pride y que luego
causaron daños a la propiedad privada o
por ejemplo un lugar donde hay eventos
drag y apuntan a estos lugares así como
a los más pequeños los que llamamos
incidentes violentos más pequeños
dirigidos a miembros de la comunidad
lgbt
por ejemplo golpes y asaltos en las
calles estamos siendo testigos de todas
estas cosas
sama también En qué estado se ha
desarrollado recientemente estos actos
de violencia contra esta comunidad ante
el lgbtiq más
la mayoría de las demostraciones que
hemos monitoreado nos dan una imagen
dimensionada de cómo Esto se está
expandiendo por los Estados Unidos la
mayoría de las manifestaciones de este
año se han concentrado en California
Texas Florida Pensilvania Carolina del
Norte Nueva York e Illinois Así que esto
es en todo el país tanto en los Estados
controlados por republicanos como los
controlados por demócratas creo que
realmente señala que este tipo de
actividad que se ha extendido y no se ha
constreñido en una sola zona de Estados
Unidos y creo que de nuevo parece que
algunos de los actos más prolíficos de
violencia política se han llevado a cabo
recientemente en Colorado así como en
Idaho Pero estos son pequeños incidentes
de los que he hablado la violencia en
múltiples o personas individuales que
atacan los eventos del orgullo que
atacan anfitriones del evento del
orgullo cosas así Estos son actos que se
dan en todo el país en diferentes
ciudades
hemos también visto que en los últimos
tiempos se ha aumentado la aparición de
estos grupos de defensa lgbti Mazo Cómo
se están organizando Cómo están
organizados
[Música]
Sí hay una presencia creciente de grupos
armados organizados para proteger los
eventos lgbtq que son objetivos de la
violencia de la extrema derecha actúan
de manera defensiva Estos son grupos que
van a aprender en algunos casos se les
llama en eventos o lugares que están
siendo objetivo de los grupos de extrema
derecha por ejemplo un restaurante que
está organizando un brunch para personas
Jack queen la lista de eventos que son
blanco de activistas de extrema derecha
como los Boys etcétera
estos grupos armados se posicionan
normalmente como una barrera entre esos
eventos y los potenciales atacantes que
han empezado a torpedear los eventos
por lo que no estamos necesariamente
viendo el mismo tipo de actividad de
activa o proactiva o ataques que
comienzan por la extrema derecha o estos
grupos es en gran medida una respuesta a
la amenaza en curso a la extrema derecha
Pero por supuesto este tipo de respuesta
aumenta las acciones reactivas y por
supuesto acostumbra a aumentar los
ataques mortales como vimos en Colorado
definitivamente aumenta las tensiones y
los riesgos de enfrentamientos violentos
entre estos grupos
en un panorama tan político tan
polarizado digamos y con la cámara
representante se encuentra En qué
situación se encuentran los ambiciosos
planes del presidente Joe biden para
este polémico también control de armas
creo que lo que podría decir es que tal
y como indicas dado lo polarizado que
está el ambiente ahora y Dado que los
republicanos han retomado el control de
la cámara de representantes es un hecho
muy improbable que la administración
biden pueda implementar políticas de
control de armas muy significativas o de
muy amplio alcance en el corto plazo lo
que eso significa es que continuaremos
viendo un aumento en la actividad Armada
en el país ya sea grupos de extrema
derecha armados protestando contra la
comunidad lgbtqvi y sus eventos o un
aumento en actos de violencia Armada
como los que vimos en Colorado es
desafortunadamente una amenaza y una
tendencia que se mantendrá con nosotros
y por un tiempo de cara al 2024